aujourd'hui je vous parlais carte bleue
banque en ligne je vous parlais d'une
banque qui est intéressante qui
s'appelle révolte c'est une vidéo qui
fait en partenariat avec révolue qui est
une banque anglaise qui propose des
services qui sont vraiment intéressantes
et pourquoi je vous en prendre pour deux
raisons principales la première c'est de
cette vidéo ce pôle santé si ça me
permet de vivre et faire vivre la chaîne
premiers points et surtout le deuxième
point qui est le plus important pour moi
c'est que lorsque je pars à l'étranger
j'ai beaucoup de problèmes beaucoup de
galères avec ma carte française ça me
coûte très cher et ça c'est une solution
qui est vraiment intéressante et qui je
pense
si vous voyagez si vous vous déplacez
peut vraiment vous aider vous
solutionner pas mal de problèmes et vous
allez voir ça c'est cool
[Musique]
j'ai un problème lorsque je pars à
l'étranger
et je vais notamment au cs par exemple
aux états unis à las vegas où je pars à
new york où je parle à londres j'ai des
problèmes parce que les devis sont pas
des euros je pense que ça vous le savez
on allait dollars aux états unis on a
les livres sterling en angleterre nous
on passe tout ça vous le savez et
lorsque vous allez payer à l'étranger
avec votre cas française nos chances
d'une banque française
un peu une banque traditionnelle un peu
standard et bien ça va vous coûter de
l'argent lorsque vous allez payer
lorsque vous avertirons distributeurs
vous prenez des frais qui tous mis
bout-à-bout coûte cher
je crois que l'année dernière je crois
que j'en eus entre 40 à 60 euros de
frais pour dix jours passés aux états
unis alors bien évidemment je pourrais
anticipé en disant tiens je vais acheter
des dollars avant de partir des mêmes
lorsque vous les achetez vous avez quand
même des frais même si c'est quand même
un peu moindre donc ça ça coûte
relativement cher ça c'est le premier
point
lorsque vous voyagez c'est un peu la
galère en plus vous avez une deuxième
règle qui pas à y perdre hyper simple
qui est souvent relativement embêtante
lorsque vous avez retiré un distributeur
un guichet qui n'est pas le guichet de
votre banque
au bout de je ne sais plus combien de
retrait eh bien vous avez des frais et
ça c'est pareil ça me fait relativement
râler parce que c'est pas très pratique
sauf que c'est pas encore très évolué en
patrouille
troisième point et non des moindres
c'est le tarif quand même relativement
exorbitant des cartes premium alors vous
me direz mais pourquoi est ce que tu te
prends un cadre très bien là tout
simplement parce que de la même manière
lorsque vous voyagez beaucoup et que
vous financez vos voyages lorsque je
parle par exemple aux crs à las vegas
c'est tout pour moi lorsque je fais des
voyages c'est pareil ça me coûte quand
même relativement cher et ce qui me
permet d'avoir en face de ça une carte
premium est simplement des garanties des
assurances et les assurances a space
aspect relativement cher et l'écart très
bien lorsque vous les payez
ça vous fait claquer un peu d'argent moi
j'ai acheté une carte cette année une
carte premium pour mes garantie voyages
quand j'ai payé 250 nouveaux trucs comme
ça rien que la carte bleue
c'est très cher à côté de ça en face
vous avez des vraies garanties
vous avez des assurances voyages la
maladie est prise en charge il ya pas
mal de choses c'est bien mais c'est cher
donc ça c'est le problème et ce qui est
cool
avec cette solution la révolte c'est
qu'effectivement ça va permettre un peu
de pallier à tous ces problèmes et ça
vous apporte des services en plus alors
je vous dis tout de suite révolue c'est
une banque en ligne qui est située en
angleterre
elle a ses points positifs elle a aussi
des points négatifs mais pour les gens
comme moi qui voyage pour des personnes
qui veulent pas liée à toutes ces
problématiques de banque qui vous coûte
cher c'est vraiment pas mal
alors j'ai deux produits à vous montrer
deux cartes bleues que j'essaye je teste
la première c'est la carte un peu
standard évolué tant que standard
ça s'ouvre comme ça ma carte et cachés
ici au dos le système est vraiment bien
foutu leur ouverture
ils ont très très beau packaging très
sympa beyond banking votre carte est là
et en plus qui écoule ses chances que
vous avez commandé votre carte en ligne
et bien c'est vous qui allez choisir
votre code pin pour votre carte ça c'est
vraiment très pratique ça évite d'avoir
un code pin qui va être je dirais
générés par la banque
là vous faites ce que vous voulez comme
vous voulez c'est cool là on est sur une
cb un peu classique mastercard
bon je vous cache pas parce que j'ai mon
coach et où la sas et loft ou skate plus
standard à côté de ça j'ai reçu une
deuxième carte c'est la carte premium et
c'est celle là qui est beaucoup plus
jolie c'est pas la carte premium vous
avez la carte stand à la carte premium
ça c'est la carte métal c'est le plus
haut de gamme et qui franchement est
vraiment très très très belle alors
l'intérêt la carte métal c'est quoi au
delà de l'objet qui est très jolie c'est
une carte tout en étal qui fait 18 g qui
quand même plus lourde qu'une carte un
petit peu standard c'est une 4 en acier
renforcé
c'est vraiment un très très bel objet un
donc la voyez j'ai mon nom qui est grave
et la juste sous mon pouce j'ai mon
numéro mon code là c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est très jolie l'objet
en lui-même est vraiment bien et cette
carte là va vous apporter pas mal de
services à vous apporter pas mal de
choses le service de révolution est très
simple c'est très facile pour s'inscrire
il vous faut un smart ou télécharger
l'application jusque là je pense que
vous vous en doutez c'est pas très très
compliqué pour ouvrir un compte c'est
simple vous vous inscrivez avec votre
numéro de téléphone bon il ya un petit
procès c'est très très très très facile
à ios android vous vous inscrivez
ensuite vous validez votre identité avec
votre passeport ou votre carte
d'identité que vous allez scanner est
c'est fait c'est ouvert vous commandez
votre carte bleue et on commence bien
évidemment il faut virer un peu d'argent
de votre compte classique banques
traditionnelles vers votre nouvelle
banque en ligne tous pas quand votre app
lire là je vous le cacher parce que vous
avez aimé car avec mon numéro de votre
carte auquel voyez ce qui est bien c'est
les services que vous avez en ligne vous
pouvez bloquer directement votre carte
si par exemple quelqu'un vous la voler
que vous l'avez perdue vous la bloquer
directement dans votre application vous
pouvez afficher votre code pin si vous
avez perdu pouvaient venir débloquer
votre code pin de tout est parti
sécurité limites que vous fixer des
plafonds mensuels de dépenses ça c'est
aussi vraiment bien vous avez une vraie
gestion de votre
j'ai de ce côté là vous avez aussi ici
accès à toutes vos statistiques
évoquons temps fort c'est vraiment cool
vous pouvez payer très facilement
quelqu'un contre évolué de vous envoyer
de l'argent c'est très très rapide il a
posé plein d'autres choses vous avez ici
par exemple plein d'infos donc vous avez
bien évidemment tous les avantages de
votre carte métal métal cashback
conciergerie tous âges et vous expliquer
dans quelques instants et vous avez bien
évidemment des assurances l'ex-équipe
tomo n'est encore que j'expliquais
salons d'aéroports où j'expliquais aussi
et des services de conciergerie la plier
pratiques faciles à utiliser vous pouvez
tout gérer vous même en interne c'est
très rapide très simple ça c'est plutôt
cool
alors il existe des comptes à titre
perso à titre professionnel nous sommes
folles perso leprohon passera ça vous
intéresse je vous invite à aller voir
directement par nous mêmes comme je le
disais vous avez une veste hong kong qui
est très facilité en plus lorsque vous
faites des achats vous avez une
notification à chaque fois comme ça si
toutefois vous perdez votre carte où
vous la passer à quelqu'un je sais pas
opel ce que vous voulez avec votre carte
et bien moi vous avez une information
sur les transactions qui sont faites
avec votre carte bleue
vous avez des petits services en plus
comme un service de coffre fort est ce
que vous allez faire un achat par
exemple à 7 euros 50 peu importe était
bien il va y avoir un arrondi à l'unité
supérieure c'était que vous affichez 7
euros 50
ça vous dépenser 8 euros sur votre
compte et les 50 centimes de delta le
petit delta ça vous met dans un petit
coffre fort qui vous sert en gros à
faire des économies c'est intéressant
vous pouvez l'activer
c'est une option vous n'êtes pas du tout
obligé mais ça peut être bien ça coûte
un petit peu transparent vous n'avez pas
l'impression de dépenser de l'argent et
pourtant vous faites des économies vous
mettez de l'argent directement souvent
le matin
ce qui est surtout très intéressant
c'est que vous n'avez pas de frais de
change dans 29 pays jusqu'à 6000 euros
par mois alors ça fait quand même une
certaine somme après vous avez des frais
qui vont s'appliquer
ça c'est vraiment toi pas c'est vraiment
le service que je trouve le plus
intéressant lorsque je voyage lorsque je
vais à l'étranger ailleurs je peux
l'utiliser ça me permet effectivement de
ne pas avoir beaucoup de fric voyez des
frais entre 40 à 60 euros que j'ai pu
avoir
lorsque je suis parti aux états unis bas
c'est de l'argent que j'aurais pu garder
pour dépenser autre chose faire un
cadeau ou je ne sais pas quoi et en plus
dans les pas de frayeur ce qu'on allait
retirer de l'argent à des distributeurs
comme ils n'ont pas de banque en
physique qui n'ont pas de guichen
physique et ça c'est un petit peu
compliqué qu'ils vous dire dès lors que
vous allez retirer un autre distributeur
on vous prend des frais vous n'avez pas
de frais jusqu'à 200 euros par mois sur
la carte standard 400 euros par mois sur
la carte premium et 600 euros par mois
sur la carte métal au delà de ça il vous
facture 2 % de frais comme je le disais
en préambule aux plantes est très
intéressant qui pour moi est le nom du
point essentiel c'est la sueur
médical je suis parti en vacances en
famille en début d'année mon fils a été
malade on a été voir le médecin qui l'a
dit bon écoute et pas de souci par
contre ça va me coûter 120 ou 140 euros
la consultation des généralistes qui
après vous dis bah écoutez on va quand
même vérifier on vous envoie à l'hôpital
je vous dis même pas les factures on va
faire des examens ça vous coûte une
fortune plus contre visite du médecin
fin bref ça coûte une fortune à peu près
d'am estimées à 500 euros de frais à
l'étranger
heureusement on avait pris une assurance
médicale pour notre voyage
mais si vous prenez une carte très bien
vous n'avez pas ces frais avancés alors
faites attention parce que la carte
révolue tu es bien mais vous avez une
assurance maladie uniquement pour le
propriétaire de la carte pas pour la
famille à faire gaffe mais lorsque vous
voyagez une fois de plus vous même
beaucoup à l'étranger
cette carte là peut vous aider en termes
d'assurance maladie alors vous avez
aussi des assurances pour les vols
retardés pour les bagages perdus ruth
madoff
vous avez pas mal de petites garanties
qui sont très intéressante pour moi
lorsque vous allez également voyager
alors bien évidemment je vous le dis
anecdotiquement mais vous vous en
douterez il faut avoir payé votre voyage
avec votre carte sinon ça marche pas ça
c'est des avantages carte premium métal
vous avez aussi l avantage qu
intéressant c'est que vous avez un
service client prioritaire que vous
pouvez joindre et vous avez des cartes
effet vers la carte fnr c'est vraiment
intéressant pour l'achat en ligne par
exemple vous allez acheter je sais pas
sur n'importe quel site et vous n'êtes
pas à l'aise avec les le fait de donner
mon numéro de carte bleue bien vous avez
une carte effet bien son coup une carte
à usage unique c'est une carte que vous
allez utiliser sur un site pourra les
payer en ligne et qui du coup ne va pas
être votre carte principale ce qui fait
que vous risquez pas de faire pirater
vous allez acheter avec et après exit la
carte c'est plutôt sécuriser tout ça
vraiment intéressant je trouve ça
dommage que les banques plus
traditionnels ne fasse pas ce genre de
service pour les personnes qui voyagent
beaucoup vous avez accès aux passes
lange qui dans les aéroports et le
premier accès est gratuit
après ces 28 euros par personne et par
axe et c'est relativement cher mais si
vous faites des grands voyages et vous
avez une escale qui est très longue
croyez-moi 28 euros pour vous poser
prendre une douche manger boire un coup
ou travailler ça n'a pas de prix pour
femmes 6,28 euros et avec la carte métal
vous avez du cashback se dire que
lorsque vous allez faire des achats on
va vous reverser une partie de la somme
lorsque vous allez acheter en europe
c'est 0,1 pour cent de la somme qui vous
est reversée c'est pas grand chose mais
lens vous allez acheter en dehors de
l'europe c'est 1%
c'est pas non plus énorme mais bon ça
existe
c'est pas notre cas de récupérer un
petit peu donc dans l'absolu pourquoi
pas et vous avez un service de
conciergerie avec cette petite carte
lorsque vous voulez réservé à l'hôtel
réservé un restaurant acheter une place
de concert vous connecter en ligne vous
marquez votre quête et vont le faire à
votre place vous vous aussi faire
quelques demandes un peu exclusive à la
différence je dirais de cartes plus
traditionnels même de black card de
moralité compagnie ou là vous allez
pouvoir joindre quelqu'un au téléphone
là vous ne gagnez pas vous gérer tous
directement dans votre application
alors si on évolue vous avez trois
offres principales le standard premium
étage vous lisez ce qui est cool avec le
standard c'est qu'elle est gratuite vous
avez accès à votre compte gratuit vous
pouvez 150 de vie soit vous avez pas mal
de possibilités c'est déjà très bien
et surtout ça vous coûte absolument rien
l'offre premium qui as intéressante qui
est franchement comment une très bonne
alternative à 799 par mois qui va coûter
en tout 95 euros 88 pas rempli leur
métal la plus belle offre ou en plus et
surtout avoir leur trou distributeurs
jusqu'à 600 euros par mois
et bien évidemment le cash back et
surtout le service de conciergerie qui
vraiment pas mal 13 euros 99 par mois
soit 167 euros 1,88 par an et en plus de
ça si vous vous occupez de quelques
monnaies si vous l'achetez décrypte
monnaies les gérer cette carte là vous
le permet il ya un vrai service avec la
carte métal ça c'est très bien mais
aussi d'écouter un petit peu négatif
lorsque vous allez sur une banque
anglaise révolte
ça va être compliqué de demander à votre
employeur de virer votre argent
directement là dessus il ya des
employeurs qui accepteront de le faire
et qu'ils n'accepteront pas pour pallier
au problème c'est pas très compliqué
vous prenez une banque standard en
france fait virer votre argent prenez
pas de carte bleue a beaucoup coûté de
l'argent et ensuite ce que vous faites
et vous fait un virement automatique
tous les mois qui part d'un compte à
l'autre
vous pouvez le gérer comme ça c'est très
simple c'est bien c'est pas un produit
qui va être forcément destiné à tout le
monde mais je trouve vraiment très
intéressante si vous voyagez beaucoup si
vous êtes amenés souvent aller à
l'étranger ou même si vous avez une fois
par an deux fois par an avec ce type de
carte c'est bien d'autant plus poussée
des cartes vous avez quand même des
garanties des assurances coûtent moins
cher que ce que vous allez trouver en
france à la concurrence et même si vous
voyagez pas beaucoup cette carte peut
être atteinte n'a pas forcément là mais
time en tout cas ne serait ce que le
compte gratuit est vraiment intéressant
parce que vous permet de ne pas avoir de
frais lorsque vous allez aux
distributeurs sont permet d'avoir une
carte gratuite ça c'est plutôt cool de
pouvoir tout gérer directement depuis
votre application vous avez une vraie
gestion de vos comptes vous pouvez
complètement manager voir quel argent
est parti dans telle ou telle catégorie
vous avez
vision d'ensemble donc pour la gestion
des comptes c'est vrai que c'est plutôt
intéressant
les banques en ligne se développe
énormément avec des offres toujours plus
intéressantes
forcément elles vont avoir des coûts -
parce qu'elles n'ont pas d'agencé n'ont
pas de présence physique
elles n'ont pas de dab à côté de ça elle
vous propose des syndics sont vraiment
bien moins cher pertinence et la banque
de demain la banque traditionnelle telle
qu'on la connaît aujourd'hui je sais pas
comment elle va réussir à perdurer face
à une concurrence comme celle là où je
vous le dis vous avez des comptes avec
une carte qui est gratuite et une carte
comme ça qui vous coûte 167 euros
c'est vraiment bien vous comparez à la
concurrence d'aller voir une blague
qu'une bande d'élite rien n'a pour 250
euros 300 euros en fonction de votre
banque donc c'est vrai ça c'est plutôt
cool je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous voyagez beaucoup est-ce
que vous avez des problèmes de devises a
beaucoup trop relativement cher est ce
que vous pensez qu'une solution comme
révolue pourrez-vous solutionner la vie
si oui tant mieux c'est plutôt cool
d'ailleurs moi c'est un truc puis
toujours dans mon portefeuille lorsque
je pars à l'étranger ça m'évite de me
taper des frais et allez savoir que
j'aime pas donné de l'argent à la banque
pour des frais comme ça ça peut toujours
aller vous invite à marquer tout ce que
vous en pensez en bas directement en
commentaire et si elle vous intéresse
7/4 cette solution vous intéresse vous
avez un code en bas bois y aller vous
dis à demain
prenez soin de vous chacha ouf